Hãy không có phòng ngạch, chương vòng 2 mịt tương dự qua,
lực lượng ngạch tấn công một chăm 5,000 tạo quay nè,
tập trung và cơ sở như liệu năng lượng hạch tấn đường sát
và kênh bài không người lại tâm xa.
Fíng ngạch cho biết đã phá huy như khi tài,
bao gồm sẽ tăng sẽ bóng hết, chân địa pháu,
của một số khó đạn và tý vị các chỉ liệt tự.
Tại các hướng, Procrops, khá kiết và Coupions,
ngạch hợp định đã đề luôn như được phản công của quay nè.
Ở chương lượng lại, không quân u quay nè thông báo,
ngạch là sự dùng 2 tí lượng đàn đào,
ích cân đo em và 1 chăm 2 mịt tảm mấy bài không người lại,
trong tất cả tập kích và đêm 1 xa thông mì một,
trong đó chỉ có một chứ bị bản hạch hộ lãnh chẳng,
những gì mình này cho thấy mức độ các thằng bởn nửa cau và chứ có số hiệu dạm.
Bình cạnh tình hình trình trình sự.
Đầu tần này phá vợ quay nè đã thý văn kiện cho phép kếm,
một đếm 1 trong tiêm tình ra phèu,
và các trang thí Mỹ của phòng trong thập bị tới,
cho thấy phân tay có được cùng có hỗ trợ quân sự chỗ khơi nè.